tomorrow night 48 hours investigates the
unsolved murder of a popular teacher in
western pennsylvania it's been more than
three and a half years since rachel
del tondo was shot and killed and there
still has not been an arrest in the case
now a man who has been under
investigation in her killing has been
convicted of a different murder 48 hours
correspondent erin moriarty reports now
on the link between that man and del
tondo
on the evening of may 13 2018 mother's
day rachel deltonda was gunned down in
her parents driveway just minutes
earlier her friend lauren watkins had
dropped rachel off they have been out
for ice cream
there was nothing unusual no unusual car
no person
anywhere in sight
but earlier that night lauren said
another friend then 20 year old former
high school football star sheldon jeter
pass them in a car
did sheldon jeter see you he did he had
messaged me on facebook and was like did
i just pass you guys and i'm like yeah
texts to others suggested jeter may have
been trying to track rachel's movements
after the shooting rachel's mother lisa
del tondo immediately suspected sheldon
jeter he was obsessed with her
he told me he's in love with her but
jeter's attorney michael santacola says
jeter did not kill rachel deltando
there's no evidence there that ties into
the crime
then nearly two years to the day that
rachel was killed sheldon jeter was
accused of murdering a close friend
tyrek pugh
the night pew was killed he and jeter
were also out for ice cream later a
series of surveillance cameras captured
sheldon jeter and tyrek pugh driving
toward the area where pugh was found
shot seven times
minutes after the shooting jeter is seen
arriving home alone
police later found the gun used to kill
pew under jeter's mattress
beaver county district attorney david
lozier
we have dna evidence we have video
on june 23 2021 jeter was found guilty
of pugh's murder and his troubles may
not be over
48 hours has learned that a pennsylvania
state grand jury has heard evidence
about jeter's possible involvement in
the murder of rachel deltando
aaron moriarty joins us now erin so
sheldon jeter is guilty of that other
murder why is he suspected in the
teacher murder well i want to make a
point though that this is a true
whodunit i mean it is not absolutely
sheldon at all what we do know is that
she was likely killed by someone she
knew because she was coming home it's
late at night someone lured her to the
end of the driveway and then shot her
point-blank
they look at sheldon because she had
been mentoring him and that relationship
may have turned romantic he had been 17
at the time 30. we've heard that kind of
story before but as you also heard
sheldon's attorney says there is no
evidence that ties him to it um and
there may have been other people who
were angry with her yeah but as your
reporting showed there was a student who
might have passed sheldon on the road on
the way in the direction of it was
sheldon but with other people i mean it
did make him look bad but there's no
evidence to time to the murder looking
bad doesn't mean you committed that's
right exactly as we know when i come
here all the time with my stories
about people wrongly convicted yes those
stories yeah aaron moriarty thank you
very much you can watch aaron's full
report who killed rachel del tondo on 48
hours tomorrow night at 10 9 central
here on cbs and on the viacom cbs
streaming service you know it it's
called paramount plus